Okay.
Here's the plan for today.
Uh,
I want to do one last foray into relativity theory.
and,
uh,
this is going to be a tricky one,
so I hope you're all feeling mentally strong this morning.
Uh,
if not,
we,
Gosh,
we should've ordered coffee for everyone.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
and in so doing,
I want to introduce a one t concept and also answer at least three of the
questions that you guys have asked,
uh,
before in a more,
in,
in more depth and also relate the whole thing back to black holes.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
having done that,
we'll,
we'll have some more questions.
And then having done that,
I want to get back to astronomy.
That is to say two things in the sky that actually manifests these relativistic
effects.
So that's where we're going today.
Uh,
and along the way,
as I said,
uh,
we'll deal with some of the questions you've been asking in a,
in a,
uh,
in a deeper kind of way in particular.
So questions,
watch out for the answers to these questions.
Somebody asked,
uh,
what's special about special relativity and what general about general
relativity,
how do they relate?
So we'll come back to that one.
Uh,
somebody also asked why use the speed of light to convert a time into space and
vice versa to get them in the same coordinate system.
So why,
uh,
use C to convert,
time to space and vice versa.
And then also there was the question of,
you know,
what is the mathematical formulation of general relativity?
Uh,
so how,
uh,
to express,
ah,
general relativity in some kind of equation.
And uh,
we'll get to the key equation,
uh,
which is something called a metric,
for general relativity.
And then we're going to stop because to go on from there is a fairly heavy
calculus and we're just not going to do that,
but I want to get as least that far.
Okay.
So let's go back to special relativity for a minute.
So special.
Okay.
Relativity,
uh,
flat space time,
no gravity.
And you'll recall what happens as you get close to the speed of light.
All sorts of things that you thought were kind of constant and properties of
objects like mass and length and duration and duration of time and things like
that all start to get weird and change.
So length
time,
okay.
Mass.
All these things vary with the velocity of the person doing the measuring.
Uh,
and so you could ask the question,
is there anything that doesn't fare it?
Uh,
is there anything that an invariant,
and the answer is yes,
there are some things that don't vary.
So some things are invariant.
Uh,
and uh,
Einstein actually said later in his career that it's actually the invariants
that are important,
not the things that change.
And so he should have called his theory,
uh,
invariant theory instead of relativity theory.
Think of what that would've done to pop philosophy,
right?
Instead of saying,
oh,
everything is relative,
all this stuff,
you would have had the exact same theory,
you would have called it invariance theory and the pop philosophy interpretation
of this would be some things never change.
Uh,
and it would have been a whole different concept in,
uh,
three in the morning dorm room conversations.
Okay.
Uh,
so some things are in variant.
What things now?
Uh,
let me first give you a little bit of a metaphor and then come back to how this
really works.
Uh,
in space time.
Supposing you're just looking at an x,
y coordinate system and you have two points in a two dimensional space.
So here's a point and here's a point.
Now,
if you arrange for some kind of coordinate system,
here's a coordinate system.
Uh,
this is x.
This is why,
and you ask how far apart these points are a well,
you can do that.
Uh,
let's see.
they're separated in x by this amount here,
uh,
which we'll call delta x and they are separated.
And why by this amount here and that Delta y,
but of course,
those quantities depend on the orientation of your coordinate system.
If I now take this coordinate system and I shift it like this,
uh,
now,
it's going to be totally different.
Now I'm going to have,
uh,
x look like this.
Yeah.
And I'm going to have y Delta y look like that.
So Delta wise gotten a whole lot smaller.
Delta x has gotten a whole lot bigger.
Uh,
and all I did was twist the,
the coordinate system.
Yeah.
You still get the same distance.
Thank you very much.
That's exactly right.
The distance is invariant.
The x coordinate and the y coordinate those vary with the coordinate system,
but the distance is the same.
That's exactly the point.
Uh,
and so the quantity,
so four,
let me summarize this.
Four points on a two d space.
Uh,
Delta x varies Delta y fairies,
but there is a quantity that is invariant.
Uh,
and that is uh,
we'll let you call it delta x squared plus Delta y squared,
which is the distance squared,
Delta d squared.
And this is invariant
and it doesn't matter which way you twist things around that will,
uh,
that quantity will remain the same.
So,
uh,
in,
now imagine that you've got,
uh,
events
in space time.
Okay.
So an event,
it's based time has three spacial coordinates and one time coordinate.
So it's basically a point in a four dimensional space,
uh,
and as your velocity changes,
yeah,
changes the,
uh,
distance and time also change.
That's the equivalent of rotating the coordinate system,
but there is something that doesn't change.
Uh,
and let me write that down.
this is usually given the Greek letter Tao squared.
Uh,
and this is equal to Delta x squared plus Delta y square plus Delta z squared
minus c squared,
Delta t squared.
Uh,
and this is invariant.
This is an invariant interval,
uh,
sometimes called proper distance.
But,
uh,
and uh,
as you,
uh,
as you change your velocity as the space as the mass is the just time all change
this quantity,
uh,
describing the separation of two events.
Uh,
so this describes the separation of two events that quantity changes.
It doesn't change that quantity is in varied.
Uh,
and okay,
so now this answers one of the questions that was asked before.
Why does one use c squared or c to transform the space,
coordinate into the,
into the time coordinating back?
It's because you need the c squared here in order to make this invariant.
Uh,
if you're calculating the distance,
if you use a x squared plus one half y squared or some other constant times y
squared,
a,
you're not going to get something that's invariant.
And it's only when you use the see here that you end up with something that's
invariant.
And so,
uh,
if you think about these as representing the four coordinates of the system,
it's clear this one coordinators,
the x one is why one is z,
just as you would expect.
Uh,
and then there's this other coordinate which is c times t,
uh,
but it's negative.
So it has to be times the square root of,
of,
of one.
So the four coordinates in space time can be thought of as x,
Y,
z.
And I see tea if you want to think of it that way.
And the time coordinates imaginary cause when you square it,
you have to end up with a negative number.
Uh,
don't worry about the details of that.
Um,
but uh,
but the see the presence of the c squared here is why you have to use C in
particular to get from tea.
Uh,
from time to space and back.
And that's necessary because this is the thing that doesn't vary with,
uh,
with philosophy.
All right,
so this is actually kind of a weird expression because unlike the distance
between two points,
uh,
and,
and you'll notice these three terms put together,
that's just the distance square,
uh,
ordinarily,
but that is not invariant to any more because there's this other term here which
can vary.
Um,
unlike the distance,
this doesn't have to be positive.
You've got three different cases here.
Uh,
this interval,
uh,
can be zero four different points in ordinary distance.
It can only be zero if the two points are the same,
but this can be zero for different points or different events.
It can be zero,
it could be negative,
and it can be positive.
So what does that mean?
What happens when it's zero?
So if the interval is zero,
that means that the distance between the events in light years,
for example,
is equal to the time separation to the time separation
in years.
Okay.
Because that,
because this term has to be exactly equal to that term there,
uh,
in order for them to subtract out and get zero.
And the c squared converged from like years,
two years in back again.
Uh,
and so what does that mean?
That means if you,
if you emit a photon
at one event,
that same photon
can,
uh,
if it's going in the right direction,
be present at the second event.
So if you ride along with light,
uh,
you'll see both the,
you'll,
you'll participate in both these events.
So you sit at event one,
uh,
you flash a light,
you ride along with the expanding a light waves from,
from,
from that event,
and you get to,
uh,
something one light year away.
Exactly a year later.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
if the second event is one light year away and distance and a year later in
time,
uh,
that same photon will,
will be present at the second event is at the first event.
Uh,
so things that have at one of these intervals of zero,
uh,
are separated by an appropriate amount so that the same ray of light can
participate in both of them.
So if the interval,
let's keep that up there for a minute.
Uh,
if the interval
yeah.
Is Negative,
what does that mean?
The distance is less than,
uh,
the light travel time.
Yeah.
So the Photon,
yeah.
Uh,
is already past the second event.
Okay.
So if you were to emit a ray of light at a event,
number one,
uh,
it would have passed,
the second event by the time,
uh,
by the time it occurred,
the photon has already gone by.
Uh,
and similarly,
if the interval is positive,
um,
then the light photon hasn't reached event to,
hasn't yet reached
you vent to.
Now this is important because this means that you can't
communicate
from event one,
two event too.
So if you're at event too,
you don't know what happened at event one,
because even if you'd sent out a signal radio,
radio signal or whatever,
uh,
it would not have reached you by the time event to takes place.
So you can't communicate from event to event to,
and similarly,
you can't travel
from event one and reach event too,
because
you'd have to go faster than the speed of light to do it.
Okay.
These kinds of intervals,
these negative intervals,
these are called timelike,
uh,
because the time term is larger than the distance turn.
And these kinds of intervals are called space,
like,
okay.
Intervals.
Okay.
And,
uh,
you can only travel or communicate over time,
like intervals.
Yes.
Uh,
so there events or you can think of them as point in space time.
So they have a particular position in space and a particular point in time.
So they can be described by four numbers,
three spacial coordinates and a time coordinator.
Uh,
they can be anything,
you know,
turning on a light,
uh,
doing,
doing anything you want to do or receiving a photon,
whatever it,
whatever it is,
but there,
uh,
points in a four dimensional space time and therefore require four numbers to
describe them.
Okay.
And Do,
you can only get from one to another if they're separated by a time like that is
to say a negative,
uh,
interval.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this expression,
Joel,
right down,
again,
this is called a metric.
And the particular metric that I've written down here is the metric for flat
space.
Because remember this is special relativity.
There's no masses,
no curvature of space,
none of that stuff yet.
This is the metric for flat space.
Yeah.
With no mass present.
And there are many other metrics possible.
Uh,
anytime you add mass or do other things,
uh,
you get,
different kinds of metrics,
more complicated than this.
So what's special about special relativity is that you use the metric
appropriate for flat space as opposed to the many other different kinds of
metrics that you can use in,
uh,
in general relativity,
which has a much more general form for the metric.
Uh,
I should say,
uh,
you can also write this down.
You can write down the spatial terms here,
uh,
in,
in polar coordinates.
Remember polar coordinates,
polar coordinates.
You described a position in space instead of with Xyz.
You describe it with a radius,
a distance from zero and some angles and it turns out that's convenient to do.
So let me write this down in polar coordinates or in polar.
Okay.
Uh,
yeah,
that's an r.
Let me write that explicitly.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
an Omega,
that some angle and then the tea thing remains the same
and I've pulled a little bit of a notational fast one on you here.
Uh,
I've gone away from the deltas and I've written these down as d.
This is the differential d,
those of you who have taken some calculus a,
we'll remember this.
If this were a calculus based course,
I would explain why I did that.
Uh,
but I'm not going to,
uh,
so,
just,
just allow me this slight of hand here for technical reasons,
these have to be differential.
Yes,
I do need a second angle term,
I should say.
Good point.
Uh,
you need to ankles and a,
and a distance in,
in three space.
This,
uh,
this,
capital Omega here is actually,
uh,
this Cap Omega squared is actually a sign theta d theta defy a,
which is the correct form.
And so you could,
you could write out both terms here,
but in fact this one isn't going to change,
but you're absolutely right.
In principle,
you need two angles.
Okay.
Why have I done this?
Excellent question.
Uh,
I asked myself a question at this point.
Where am I going?
Uh,
what I want to do now is write down a curve,
a different metric.
The metric that actually involves curved space and uh,
the presence of a mass.
And this is something called the Schwartz Shield metric.
You remember Schwartz Shield,
he had a radius.
Uh,
and this is the appropriate metric for the presence of a single point to mass
at the center of the Coordinate System at r equals zero.
That's why I put it into polar coordinates because,
uh,
the presence of the mass is going to change the space time as a function of
distance from a radial distance from where the masses.
And so it's much more convenient for the Schwab showed radius,
uh,
for the Schwartz showed metric to use this in polar coordinates.
So here's the Schwartz show metric.
Uh,
D Tao squared.
That's the,
this is the interval is equal to d r over one minus R s over her.
So that's just like the,
just like the flat term,
except with something in the,
in the denominator there plus r squared,
the Omega squared,
that's just like the flat metric.
Uh,
and then the,
uh,
whoops,
this had better be minus,
uh,
c squared,
one minus R s over r d t squared where our assets,
this wardrobe,
a radius which we've had before,
which is two g m oversee square.
Okay.
So this is just like the flat metric with two exceptions.
It's got a term in the radio,
uh,
part of this one minus r s over our,
and it's got that same term,
but this time in the numerator,
uh,
in the time,
in the time term here.
Now what do you do with this,
uh,
with such an equation?
Well,
we've done a,
in special relativity.
We've dealt with these kinds of things.
What you do is you start taking the limited cases.
You say,
okay,
what happens?
Uh,
when it's getting really close to flat on the one hand and what's happening when
it's getting very seriously relativistic on the other hand.
So let's do that.
Uh,
if our s over our goes to zero,
then the metric turns into the flat metric.
Because if rs over R is zero,
this term disappears because it's one minus zero and it just cancels.
This term disappears and you recover the flat metric.
This happens in two cases.
Uh,
if the mask goes to zero,
then our s goes to zero and you recover the flat metric.
Or if our gets really big,
then rs over our goes to zero.
And again,
you recover the flat metric.
So in there are two situations where Schwab chill metric blends smoothly into,
uh,
the ordinary flat space.
One is if the mass is zero,
that's not surprising.
If the mass is zero,
then the then spacetime isn't curve.
Or alternatively,
if you're really,
really far away from the mass,
if r is much,
much bigger than the Schwartz drilled radius,
you're way out there.
Uh,
there's no gravitational effect.
Spacetime remains flat.
So these are the,
this is the limiting case where you recover special relativity.
Now the other case is when our gets close to the Schwab chilled radius and
approaches it.
So then one minus R s over our approaches zero cause these two are going to get
closer and closer together.
One minus one is zero.
What happens then?
So this is now first of all,
in physical terms,
you're getting really close to the Schwab chilled radius.
So now what happens to the metric if you do that?
The uh,
uh,
the Dr term
gets very big
cause it's got a zero in the denominator.
The DT term gets really small
cause it's got that,
uh,
that thing that's going to zero in the numerator.
Uh,
fine.
What does that mean?
Well remember this is the negative term.
This is the positive terms.
So the positive terms getting really,
really big,
the negative terms,
getting really,
really small and that means that,
uh,
all intervals
are gradually becoming space.
Like
what do I mean by that?
Uh,
well,
the negative term is getting small.
The Pot,
one of the positive terms is getting big.
So the sum of those tends to be positive.
It's becoming more and more positive.
Positive.
Uh,
intervals are the space,
like intervals and you can't communicate or travel across space like intervals.
When you get all the way to the Schwab chilled radius,
this blows up completely becomes infinite.
This becomes zero.
And there are no time like intervals.
There are no time like intervals that cross the event horizon.
That's why you can't get out.
This takes us back to the basic principle of black holes.
So,
uh,
cannot,
communicate.
Okay?
Or travel over space like intervals.
And so you can't cross r equals let's watch shield radios.
All right,
let's see.
Let me write the thing down again here for you.
Okay.
So that's the metric we're worrying about here.
And now,
uh,
let's think about what happens inside the Schwab showed radius are less than our
Schwab chill.
That means the Dr term becomes negative
because one minus R s over our,
uh,
if rs is bigger than our,
then this term is,
this term is greater than one and this whole thing is less than zero and the
signs change and the Dt term becomes positive.
So that means yes,
this is the time term
where this one is the space like term cause it's positive.
Okay.
That's what I meant three,
four or five lectures ago when I said that inside,
uh,
the Schwab Shield radius,
when you're inside the swatch would radius space and time reverse.
It's a sign change in the metric.
That's what it means.
Uh,
and you can only travel,
uh,
along negative intervals.
Yeah.
That means you have to move in are the same way outside the Schwartz real
radius.
You have to move in t uh,
and uh,
but notice it's only the radial term.
This term hasn't changed.
You could go around in circles,
but whatever you do,
you still have to move.
As it turns out toward the center of the thing in radius,
in order to have a timeline interval.
And so a motion
in our is required for,
uh,
inside the Swat showed radius,
whereas motion in t is required outside.
Yeah.
So space and time reverse,
all of which is very nice.
Uh,
but I've left out something,
uh,
I've left something out,
which is the fact how inside the event horizon,
how do you know that this is still the metric one could invent some function
that looks just like this outside the Schwab showed radius,
but then it looks like something else inside the structural radius.
And because no communication across the swore chilled radius as possible,
you'd never be able to test it.
And so this is how one gets away with doing non testable,
uh,
physics.
You say,
well,
we're just going to assume that the metric hasn't changed.
Why should it change after all?
It's a,
it's the same equation.
Uh,
but uh,
but inside the SRA trialed radius,
you can't actually test this outside.
The Schwartz showed radius.
You can test it because you see,
uh,
whether,
objects behave as they ought to behave in a space that's curved in this
particular way,
you know,
spacetime that's curved in this particular way.
Um,
and so this is,
uh,
what I meant by,
five classes would go by saying space and time reverse these two,
uh,
quantities,
reverse their signs.
All right,
that's as far as we can go because the next thing that one would want to do is
you find out what the equation is for finding out how things move in these,
in these,
uh,
curved space times.
Basically you remember things go from one event to another in the shortest
possible path.
That's the equivalent of a straight line.
That means if you integrate over D Tau,
it has to be minimized.
So you minimize this integral that tells you how things move.
We're not going to do that,
uh,
sighs of relief,
um,
and uh,
uh,
because,
for obvious reasons.
Um,
so this is this,
this is as far as we can go just to write down the metric here.
So let me now pause,
uh,
four questions and then we're going to go back and talk about,
astronomy about things in the sky that actually,
uh,
exhibit these relativistic behaviors.
Yes,
sorry.
Oh,
ah,
an interval.
So what I'm doing is I'm taking two events,
each of which is one of these points in space time.
And I'm asking,
uh,
what is the interval between them of what is,
you could measure the distance between them.
You could measure the time from one to one event to another,
but as it turns out,
those aren't in variants.
And so there's this other thing,
the,
the metric which is invariant.
And so that's a,
that's a s a measure and invariant measure of how,
uh,
of how separated these two events are.
So I've,
I've chosen you take to events and you ask yourself,
are they separated by zero,
a positive quantity or a negative quantity?
Whether whereby separation,
I mean,
this curious combination of space
time.
Yeah,
it's an intro level.
Think of thing.
Let me go back to the analogy.
I started with a,
here's in two spatial dimensions,
x and y.
Uh,
here are two points and depending on how I set the coordinate system up,
the x distance,
the x difference between them and the wide difference between them can change,
but the distance is always the same.
Uh,
so now I've got two points with each,
with an x,
Y,
Z and a t.
And depending on how I change my velocity are my coordinates,
uh,
the particular values of x,
Y,
Z and t can change.
But the,
uh,
this Delta Tau a squared defined by,
I'm in flat space now,
right.
Uh,
this
separation,
this interval between those two points,
this is the invariant in the same way that the distance between two points
doesn't change.
If you change the coordinate system,
even though the x and y separations do,
it gives you no,
well,
it combines these four things into one thing that doesn't change.
That's the point.
Yes.
Um,
as the,
is the integral from zero,
it basically to medicine appear simultaneous
as,
as the,
yeah,
exactly.
Wow.
Well,
okay,
so there's two different ways things can appear simultaneously.
One is if they are two different events in space time,
uh,
and uh,
I had light travels from one and they're exactly separated by,
by,
uh,
the amount of time between them as the same as the distance between them.
If you multiply by sees quick,
uh,
they can also appear simultaneously if they are the same point as each other.
Uh,
and then everything goes to zero.
And it's only in that second case that,
uh,
that it,
that the Newtonian concept of simultaneous kicks in simultaneous,
uh,
is usually taken to mean that the time separation is zero.
Two things happen simultaneously when they happen at the same time.
Okay.
The earth on earth that did the,
the,
uh,
the distances and the stamp,
the velocities and the gravitational fields are never so strong that you have
any trouble,
uh,
that,
that the Delta t changes significantly depending on what your,
what your point of view is.
So,
you know,
our everyday life we have a strong concept of simultaneity.
It's two things that happen at the same time.
Turns out though that if you move it close to the speed,
if you observe to events to be at the same time,
and I'm moving at close to the speed of light,
I don't observe those two events at the same time,
even though you do.
Uh,
and so at that point you have to abandon the new Tony and concept that uh,
Delta t equals zero tells you the two events are simultaneous and the whole
concept of simultaneity he takes on a different cash.
Other questions?
Yes.
Uh,
okay.
So these units can be,
uh,
can be any units of length you like provided the,
any units of length you like provided the time units are uh,
uh,
are related to it by sea.
That is to say if your distance units are light years,
your time units have to be years.
If you're distant units are meters,
then your time units or some kind of meter light meters.
Second thing.
Uh,
and so the only,
uh,
the only restriction on the units you use is that the time and the space units
have to be convertible into each other through c square or alternatively,
another way of saying it is you use any units you like and as long as you
expressed the speed of light in those units,
if you have a time unit in a space unit,
if you're in you,
if you're measuring your,
your space in logs in your time in fortnights,
as long as you're a c as in furlongs per fortnight,
it's gonna come out.
Okay.
So as long as it's convertible,
other questions?
Okay.
If you don't get all the details and nuances of what I,
what I've said this period,
don't worry too much about it.
Uh,
I just wanted to get the concept of the metric out there and show you how,
if you look at that equation,
uh,
these concepts of space and time reversing and so forth have a kind of
mathematical consequence as well as just,
you know,
spouting words.
Uh,
and if you get sort of the basic outline of the argument,
that's,
that's fine.
Okay.
Uh,
back to actual things in actual,
uh,
that actually exist.
Um,
so what I want to talk about now is evidence
for general relativity from
astronomical
objects,
real black hole,
stuff like that.
Now,
one of the curious things about this is that when Einstein thought all this
stuff up,
he thought it up from basically these philosophical concerns about,
uh,
about mass,
that the inertial mass turned out to always be equal to the gravitational mass.
Why would that be?
Uh,
and there wasn't when he thought it up a great body of evidence,
uh,
for grant of,
for his theory in the real world.
This is in contrast to special relativity,
special relativity.
Uh,
there were all these experiments that needed to be explained,
general relativity,
uh,
very,
very little.
In fact,
when Einstein First,
uh,
put forward the theory in 1917,
there was only one thing that had ever been observed that actually showed an
effect of general relativity.
And that was the orbit of mercury a which you're reading about for this week's
problem set.
So,
uh,
just going back a little bit,
in the 19th century,
people had observed the orbits of planets in,
uh,
in great in great detail.
And they found out that two of the planet we're moving,
uh,
in ways they couldn't quite explain.
There was very small deviations from the predictions,
uh,
or a bird in particularly.
The orbit of Uranus was a little weird.
Uh,
and that was then quickly explained by the presence of an unknown hitherto
unknown planet,
which was also exerting a gravitational force on your anus and pulling it out of
the orbit.
That it should have been by a very small amount,
uh,
because the gravitational force of another planet is very small compared to that
of the sun.
But by the middle of the 19th century,
they could measure such things,
uh,
and they therefore predicted,
okay,
the presence of this other planet,
uh,
of Neptune.
And they calculated where it should be.
And some guy went off and observed in that spot and found it predicted presence
of,
of Neptune and,
uh,
discovered.
Yeah.
Yet,
uh,
in the predicted place,
big triumph.
Everybody as if they had had Nobel prizes back then,
they would have wanted for this,
uh,
for sure.
Uh,
and then there was a whole big kerfuffle because they couldn't decide whether
the French guy had done it before the English guy or vice versa.
And,
uh,
they argued with each other for decades about who gets the credit.
But in scientific terms,
there was a prediction and the prediction was verified.
Excellent News.
Uh,
now there was also a problem with the orbit of Mercury,
also a perturbed from what you would expect.
And having had this big triumph in the outer solar system,
they figured,
well,
we know how to deal with this.
Uh,
there's gotta be another planet in there.
So they predict,
uh,
the presence of a planet called Vulcan,
which then disappears from the scientific literature until it's resurrected by
star Trek.
Uh,
but Vulcan,
the,
the concept of Vulcan was this was going to be a planet that's closer to the sun
than mercury.
That's why they haven't been able to find it because it's too near the sun to be
easily observed.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it's going to pull on mercury in such a way that it's going to explain the
problems with the orbit of mercury.
And so they then look for Vulcan in the predicted place
and they find it
and that somebody else finds it.
They find it many times,
and each time it's different,
uh,
all different and it gradually becomes clear.
Uh,
then everybody's fooling themselves,
uh,
that there is no,
this is a really hard observation to make,
right?
Because the thing is right near the sun.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so it turns out that all of this is wrong.
Uh,
none of these observations or really any good,
uh,
it's not repeatable.
So,
uh,
not really.
Uh,
and so after some attempts to find Falcon and then they rule out the presence of
fall pen and various places,
so then the people calculating the orbit tough to go back and say,
well,
it fucking isn't there.
Maybe there are two or three planets combining together to do the thing that
originally wanted,
Volk it to do.
This gets sorted out of control after a while.
And at a certain point,
people just kind of give up and they say,
well,
it's a great big mystery about mercury.
Uh,
and after a while after that,
uh,
people kind of even stopped caring,
because,
you know,
we know Newton's laws work.
This is just some weirdness about mercury that we don't understand.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
when Einstein,
yeah.
Uh,
uh,
creates his new theory of gravity,
okay.
He then computes in the new theory Mercury's orbit.
Yeah.
And he now gets something that agrees with the observations
without the need for a new planet.
And so what happened was Mercury's orbit is a little different from the
Newtonian prediction.
Uh,
the general relativity prediction is a little bit different in just the same way
to explain this problem that people have been trying to solve for 50 years on
successfully.
Uh,
and,
uh,
yeah,
so this was,
uh,
this was the first verification,
empirical verification of General Relativity.
And if you think about it,
you would expect that Mercury will be the place you would find this out.
Uh,
for Mercury,
uh,
r s over our,
this is the Schwartz chilled radius of the sun because that's what's doing the
gravity.
Tating is the biggest in the solar system,
uh,
because the are the distance from mercury to the sun is the smallest of any of
the planets in the solar system.
So this,
uh,
and so the relativistic effects,
the Gr,
the general relativity effect,
uh,
are,
relatively large.
But
you know,
this is still a really small number.
This is three kilometers.
The swatch of radius of the sun.
Mercury is way out there somewhere.
So even though this is the most,
this is the biggest relativistic effect in the solar system,
it still isn't that huge.
Uh,
let me,
uh,
just remind you what this effect is.
Here's the sun.
Mercury's going around the sun and it's going around in a slightly elliptical
orbit.
I'm going to draw a very elliptical orbit here,
but it's really not that big.
And there's a point in the orbit where it is closest to the sun.
That point is called the Para helion Perry for close Helio's for Sun.
Yeah.
Of
Mercury.
And in the new Tony,
in theory,
you should have exactly the same more,
but every time you should come back and the Para helion should be in the same
place.
In each successive orbit.
The orbit doesn't move or doesn't change.
But in general relativity,
the Para helion moves.
So after a while,
uh,
the Para helion will be here,
the whole orbit.
We'll kind of tip this way
and it'll look like this.
Uh,
so this is the Para helion later.
Okay.
And it looks like that.
And uh,
the ankle,
which the Para helion makes with the sun has changed.
This angle here is called the angle pair of heels and this precesses.
So this is called the precession
of the Para helion.
And it's measured in some angle per time because of the question is how long
does it take for the Paris Elian to process across some ankle.
And the key number for mercury is 43.
Arc seconds.
Remember arc seconds.
Those are small angles per century,
a really small
movement,
but something that can be measured and,
and had been measured.
And,
uh,
it's not surprising that this is small because the relativistic effects are
going to be small because the swatch old radius of the sun is really small
compared to the size of the orbit of mercury.
But this was,
uh,
this was observed,
before Einstein made his theory.
Nobody understood it.
Einstein came up with his theory of turned out,
it predicted a,
a precession of the Para helion.
And in a way that Newton didn't,
and it turned out to work out precisely.
So that was good.
Uh,
and at the time,
Einstein published the theory.
This was the only piece of evidence that it was correct.
Pretty small,
uh,
empirical verification.
And so,
uh,
let's just write down,
the fable here.
This is,
uh,
Einstein and the precession of the Para helion.
And there are two versions of the moral,
sometimes in textbooks,
you know,
uh,
they,
they make a big deal out of this.
They say,
oh,
there was this terrible problem with mercury.
And then Einstein came along with his great new theory,
solve that problem in the same way that they say there was this terrible problem
with the speed of light being constant from all frames.
And Einstein came along with special relativity and solve that problem.
That's a misreading of,
of history.
This was a byproduct of Einstein,
wasn't that there was a problem with,
uh,
the data and he went out to try and fix the theory to,
to conform with the data.
Uh,
there was very little data.
So the,
the,
the moral here is,
uh,
um,
aesthetic,
uh,
considerations,
aesthetic,
perhaps you want to call this philosophical
considerations can lead to a good new theory because he didn't really do it to
explain the data.
Uh,
this is however,
the only time I can think of where this actually happened,
this way,
every other major advance in science came about because the observers are the
experimentation or the experimenters had a problem,
uh,
but not Gr,
only for general relativity.
Now subsequent to that,
between 1917 when this theory was promulgated,
and now there have been,
uh,
a variety,
a variety of tests of general relativity using astronomical objects,
you always have to use astronomical or almost always have to use a astronomical
objects to test this because you need really strong gravitational fields and
it's hard to produce a really strong gravitational field in the laboratory.
You're kind of limited to what the earth provides you with.
And that isn't such a strong gravitational field.
Uh,
we,
we computed at some point the Schwartzwald radius of the earth are over our
Schwab Childers,
the relevant quantity,
and it's really small from the Earth's gravitational field.
So it's hard to see these things.
So all these tests tend to be astronomical in nature since then,
a variety of tests of Gr.
And,
and the punchline is that it passes all of them.
Gr is still a good theory.
There's no contradictory data.
Uh,
but the tests still aren't as strong as you might have hoped they would be.
And we'll talk about,
uh,
some of those,
on Thursday.